before joining amazon web services as an
intern i remember spending hours
watching a day in the live videos on
youtube
trying to picture what it would be like
working in a large tech company
these videos got me really excited and
although i probably wasn't making the
most out of my time watching everybody's
morning routine and free work lunches it
really motivated me to stay resilient
and not give up after every interview
rejection
there were a few things though that i
wish these videos covered
i wanted to know more about what interns
actually get to work on
how teams communicate and solve problems
together and what challenges
interns face during their short time in
the company if you're new here my name
is lucy and i make videos all about tech
career and student advice today i wanted
to talk a bit about my experiences with
amazon web services
and answer these three questions so if
you're interested in seeing more videos
like this
and you're a current or incoming intern
please consider subscribing for more
let's get into it it's nine o'clock in
the morning now
and at 10 o'clock i have a meeting with
my manager and a few of the consulting
interns
to go through the different projects
that we have over the summer and figure
out which one we want to do
so we can do them either in pairs or in
small groups or even individually
and we can choose between quite a few
technical and non-technical projects
so i thought i'd take this time to talk
a bit about
what interns actually do in internships
aside from everything you see in the
typical day in the live videos
you know apart from those coffee
catch-ups and virtual intern events
i guess what you do as an intern really
varies from company to company
and really depends on the length of your
internship so
a one month long internship could look
very different to a six month long
internship
and for example when i was at deloitte
last summer my internship was for four
weeks
and this really involved a lot of
shadowing
getting to know the team and i wasn't
specifically placed
onto a project to work on because just
because there wasn't really enough time
for you to
make much of an impact it was more about
learning about the company learning
about the team
and seeing if you like the company and
seeing if the company likes you
and on the other hand my internship with
aws i was interning for six months in
one team
and with that i was able to take
ownership of three projects
and see them end to end this was a
really good experience because
especially with a longer internship
you're not only able to be immersed in
the company culture but you're able to
make a real tangible impact in the team
that you're assigned to as well and i
think that that is
super valuable as an intern especially
when you get the chance to see what you
like
and you don't like in the company to see
if that company is right for you
so in terms of a typical day though it
really depends as well because
um it really comes down to what you want
to gain out of the internship
i think sometimes if you just want to
kind of um
like have fun and see how things go not
really set any goals
kind of like do the bare minimum to get
buyers and in turn your day might look
quite empty because if you just go to
the required meetings and kind of like
do what you're told to do
um that that would be fine like you
would still be able to
continue on with your internship and
learn a few things
but if you really want to stand out as
an intern and potentially
land a full-time role after your
internship
i think it's really important for you to
be able to set measurable goals and be
proactive about your learning
so that by the end of the internship
when you reflect you can see that
even though you were just an intern you
were able to make a contribution to the
team that you're in
and also be able to have like a graduate
position at the end
where you're able to come back to if
you're interested in staying with the
company
so i guess the main takeaway is that no
two internships are the same
some of them you might be working on
multiple projects some of them you might
be doing more shadowing and more
learning so it's really up to you to
make the most out of every opportunity
that you're offered
okay so it's 12 now and i'm gonna take a
bit of a break from using my standing
desk
after lunch i'm gonna be sitting here
and
i typically try and alternate between
using the two just to make sure that i'm
not sitting
at the same place um the entire day and
getting a lot of back pain
okay so i just had lunch and now i
wanted to talk a bit about how teams
communicate and collaborate with each
other
so i guess it really depends on the
company
and the team that you're in um and
even with amazon as well in such a big
company different teams have
different ways of doing things and from
my experience
i think what i saw that was quite common
is
having stand-ups especially during a
virtual setting having a daily stand-up
or
weekly stand up can really help keep
everyone in the team accountable
especially during interns with interns
as well sometimes you might not
understand half the things that are
being discussed in the team stand-ups
because you're working on your own
project
but it's a really good way to see how
everything fits in together in a company
which is pretty cool and at amazon and
at quite a few different companies as
well i think there's like really helpful
collaboration software so
um in amazon we use amazon chime so
there's like a video conferencing
software for us to connect virtually
um and in different companies it might
be
zoom or google me things like that and
there's also different
ways of collaborating as well in terms
of
using shared like drives
collaboration folders and
i guess another thing that we have and
um different companies have different
ways of doing this
is sort of how we brainstorm
different ideas and how we are able to
turn ideas into reality
so we have something called narratives
and also things called like prfaqs and
these are ways for us to
kind of like um generate an idea
and to be able to elaborate and expand
on it
get people's feedback and i guess the
main takeaway for interns or people who
are going into
an internship is that at the start you
might be quite overwhelmed with the
different
tools the different ways of doing things
in a company especially if you haven't
seen it being done in any other sort of
role that you were in before
so don't be afraid to ask questions um
ask what sort of
norms there are in certain teams like if
you
have a stand up that you have to go to
every single week or if you have like a
team social event
that is optional for you to attend
things like that just making sure
and clarifying what are the ways that
different teams communicate and work
together especially in a virtual setting
you might end up missing out on certain
things if you don't ask the right
questions about it
okay so it's around 5 30 now and i
wanted to talk a bit about
the challenges that you face as an
intern so i just finished work
um done for the day and this is kind of
the last part i wanted to discuss
with this video and this part is
something
i think is quite important because
there's a big emphasis
on getting that first internship there's
a big emphasis on
how to do well how to succeed the
benefits of internships but not too much
is discussed on
what challenges interns face and more
importantly how to avoid these
challenges in the first place and if you
do find yourself
having this challenge how you can kind
of work around it
so when i was doing doing some planning
last night for the video
i sort of came up with a list of things
that i personally
found challenging as an intern and
depending on people's personalities
everyone sort of gets a different set of
challenges that
they might face i think for me
specifically
some of the big ones on the board were
a fear of uncertainty feeling
overwhelmed by the amount of
information i don't know and the amount
of information that i need to know
not really sure if i'm doing well
connecting
with the team feeling like it's an
extended interview
i try not to think like that but
sometimes you feel like you're being
kind of assessed
during the process so i wanted to
kind of talk a bit about that and how
you can sort of
overcome these challenges if you face
these yourself okay so the first
challenge i wanted to talk about is the
fear of uncertainty
how you can overcome that when things
are just out of your control sometimes
you don't know
a lot of new terms and it's kind of
impossible to pick up everything at once
i think first of all recognizing that
you're not going to know everything in
the first few days
and second of all trying your best to
make sure that you
can cover a lot of things really quickly
that you're uncertain about to give
yourself more of a peace of mind so
i think for amazon what we normally get
is like an onboarding plan
so it's something that links a lot of
resources together to make sure that
we're able to
quickly figure out different processes
in the company
learn about the culture learn about what
we kind of need on our role
so i think doing that really helps
trying to
make sure that you utilize the resources
that you're given
so that you can help yourself limit that
anxiety and uncertainty that you face
and i think also just recognizing that
not everything is going to be on paper
so asking a lot of questions when you're
uncertain about something
really helps i think people especially
when you're in turn people are
always willing to help and that's
something that i really have appreciated
throughout my internship journey and has
helped me a lot with this fear of
uncertainty
one more thing you can do is to find a
mentor whether that be
within the company or outside the
company sometimes you're assigned to one
but i think sometimes
it's okay if you want to proactively
search for a mentor that's not
necessarily in your current team
i think just having someone can trust
someone you can sort of rely on
when there's questions that you want to
ask or if there's any advice that you
want to seek
it really helps remove that uncertainty
as well the second challenge that i
faced was connecting with people
in my team and outside of my team i
think in my previous internships i've
always taken
a bit longer than the other interns to
really bond
with people in the team that i was in
but working from home definitely made it
a lot worse because people talk less
about
their life their hobbies the career
aspirations things like that
when they're not in the office when
they're on a virtual time core
um working from home mainly as a new
intern
it's kind of hard to break the ice
initially
it's so it's something that you have to
consciously
try and do so what i recommend doing is
making the effort to get to know
everyone in your team so when you first
join
set up half an hour course with people
in your team and making sure that you
specify that it's specifically
just to try and get to know each other
and
to maybe for you to learn a bit about
what they do their role but you know
specifically to sort of like
get to know them as a person as well so
that way
you can break the ice early on to avoid
those initial
like awkward conversations that you have
and
making sure that you have a more
enjoyable experience working from home
because connecting with people is quite
important i think
as an intern when you can get all your
work done go above and beyond
make an impact in your team it's as good
as that is
it's very important to be able to
integrate well with the team
and trust with them and really get to
know
people as who they are outside of work
as well
the third and final challenge that i'm
going to talk about today is
sometimes feeling like your internship
is like an interview
i've heard this phrase a lot from people
in the past
and i think it's coming from good
intentions because they want you to kind
of keep it in the back of your mind that
you're kind of being assessed your
performance is being assessed
so that in the end you can receive a
return offer but
i think it's quite an unhealthy mindset
sometimes
it can get quite unhealthy especially if
you're an overthinker
you can't just kind of fixate on that
long-term end goal
and not be able to kind of focus on
other things
and it does sound a bit quite extreme
but overthinkers will kind of know what
i mean by this but i think
what really helped me overcome this
challenge and i was really lucky to be
able to
change my mindset and overcome this
challenge within the first two months of
the internship
it was to focus less about myself
um what the company can bring to me but
instead focus more on
especially since i was an intern for six
months what
i can offer to my team and what value i
can bring to the company
so with that in mind i was focusing more
on how i can make my manager's day
easier things like what help i can offer
to
others outside my team and how to be
more involved as an intern just to have
some more fun throughout my internship
experience
so with that i was able to overcome
that or like everything is an interview
sort of
mindset and i would recommend doing the
same trying to figure out
what value you can bring to the company
and this basically wraps up my video
hopefully in this video you were able to
learn more about what interns actually
do
how teams communicate and collaborate to
solve problems and what challenges
interns might face working from home
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a like and share your thoughts
down below subscribe if you want to see
more tech
student or career related advice videos
bye for now